vous vous en souvenez peut-être de cet
ours qui étaient capturés en plus marché
by au centre-ville d'ottawa c'était au
début du mois de septembre dernier
en fait un peu partout dans la région
d'ailleurs bien plus de citoyens qu'à
l'habitude ont signalé la présence des
os et martin c'est probablement en
raison d'un manque de nourriture qu'on
retrouvait dans la forêt oui c'est le
constat fait par une équipe de
chercheurs du ministère des forêts de la
faune et des parcs la fut soudain d'ours
noirs l'an dernier dans les milieux
humains dans la grande région de la
capitale nationale
ça atteint un sommet sans six ans les
petits fruits ont séché dans la forêt si
bien que ça a forcé les ours à venir à
la rencontre du milieu humain proche de
nos maisons proches de nos villes
d'ailleurs les spécimens qui font
actuellement l'objet d'une étude de bain
chez eux on constate actuellement une
perte de poids
alors je vous invite au coeur de la
forêt visiter une tanière
[Musique]
une jeune femelle endormi dans sa
tanière bienvenue au pays des ours deux
heures de route dans le pontiac quelques
kilomètres de motoneige au nord ouest
d'autres lacs puis une marche en
raquettes
une équipe du ministère des forêts de la
faune du parc mène une recherche de cinq
ans sur les ours noirs dans un contexte
de changement climatique et
d'aménagement forestier
c'est l'abbé pagny paul collier plus on
va s'approcher
fraikin exactement un projet qui permet
de recueillir de précieuses données sur
la santé des ours et mieux gérer les
zones de chasse dans quatre régions du
québec pour l'attitude diverses
l'outaouais la mauricie le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean et la gaspésie
soixante quinze bêtes dont 17 en
outaouais sont munis d'un collier
émetteur une femelle de 3 ans s'est
endormi pour l'hiver sous des racines à
l'abri de la neige abondante
en attendant l'équipe connaît bien la
baisse pour lui avoir installé un
collier en juillet dernier on chuchote
et prépare l'anesthésiant le sommeil
doit devenir profond caf avec 100 points
sans être quelqu'un de très bien convenu
injecte prenant dormir cette fois ci
mais le bruit tir l'ours de son
hibernation forcée tout à fait rêver
long on le voit nous regarde
présentement par le trou qu'on ne creuse
la femelle mécontente n'apprécie pas la
piqûre
il faut vite boucher la sortie dix
minutes plus tard
le danger est écarté on va la sortir et
commence un examen complet de l'animal
endormi
dimensions 3 température saturation le
présentement en train de mesures qu'on
avait pris quand le capturer au mois de
juillet donc ça nous permet de voir des
courbes de croissance
ceci est en discussion après une mesure
de coups une maison nano tech on une
mesure de longueur totale parce que la
longueur totale est corrélée avec
l'argile événement donc ces longues
heures dîner on suit la colonne
vertébrale jusqu'au bout de la queue là
on est venu leda regarde sur la patte
d'un corps c'est parce que des fois des
fois les dents cassées pourraient faire
en sorte qui est un petit peu moins
efficace pour trouver de la nourriture
on ajuste également le collier par
expérience qu'il faut passer mon doigt
la main au complet de façon générale les
données scientifiques colligées en mars
confirme que les ours sont un peu plus
maigre et vulnérable cette année et
qu'ils ont parcouru plus de kilomètres
pour trouver les 20 mille couleurs
par jour dont ils ont besoin pour
affronter l'hiver sans pour autant être
en danger
c'est un automne un été difficile pour
eux parce qu'ils manquent de bouffe et
la quantité de beauf dans l'habitat de
l'ours est directement liée aux
conditions climatiques
cette année la sécheresse qu'on a connue
en a ou au fait que la position de l'ue
est presque inexistante il ya beaucoup
de framboise de mûre qui ont séché sur
le plat ça explique en partie peut-être
la raison pour laquelle ils sont mus
proche des milieux humains ont à nouveau
marcher directement appliqué certaines
sources on s'entend on nous sur 17 ont
investi ce qu'ils se sont rapprochés de
la ville en outaouais l'an dernier les
agents de protection de la faune ont dû
immobiliser ou relocalisé en forêt 129
ours bien plus que par les années
passées
selon eux il est probable que 2019 soit
plus tranquille en matière de
signalements en milieu urbain une fois
la batterie de tests sur l'animal
effectués ne reste plus maintenant qu'à
leur retourner dans sa tanière c'est ce
que présentement font les techniciens
tout ça sera recouvert de sapinage
également de neige
l'ours va ressortir quelque part au mois
de mai à la fonte des neiges se seront
ni vu ni connu ici martin robert
radio-canada dans le pontiac là